[Music]
hello everybody my name is Geoffrey Noer
and I'm here as a product manager for
Google Cloud Storage and I'm here with
Michael you a technical lead with with
GCS hey everyone and we're here to
present the best practices for storage
classes reliability performance and
scalability and before before I get
started I wanted to ask for a quick show
of hands how many of you in the audience
are actually currently using Google
Cloud storage and then how many people
have not used it yet but are interested
so it's it's a good mix more of you are
probably using it already than than not
I'll go ahead and start with a
relatively quick you know leap through
the the feature set and like and the
capabilities of quick introduction and
then we'll cut over to covering some of
the the key areas and Michael will
rejoin us for a demo in a few slides so
like I said we'll start with the
introduction the three content areas
that are particularly interesting we
felt to cover today included a content
storage and delivery also compute
analytics and machine learning and then
finally back up an archive all of those
are use cases that we have many many
customers utilizing GCS today so let's
start with that introductions so in the
so cloud storage it's actually object
storage hopefully all of you know so
it's we also have block and file
products as part of GCP but our our
cloud storage product is our object
storage offering which is really the the
native cloud format for data and you
know what makes in the end the the key
values of our solution are that we're
trusted that we're secure were smart and
simple and you'll see all of these
reflected in the capabilities of the
product so you know why have why have a
cloud storage offering it all comes back
to you know the origins of Google and
the the data centers that we've we've
established
around the world to deliver all of the
the products and services that you're
familiar with outside of of GCP outside
of the cloud product and we had to build
extremely fast capable networks across
the globe we had to create exabytes of
storage capacity to handle all of the
properties like Gmail and YouTube and
search and so why not I have a cloud
offering that would allow customers to
directly use the Google infrastructure
that has been built successfully over
all of these years so that's one of the
the key differentiators for cloud
storage even though we're a storage
platform and storage product in the end
it's the network that makes is one of
the biggest advantages of Google cloud
platform it's hundreds of thousands of
miles of fiber-optic cable across the
ocean as well as within countenance and
we have more edge and peering
capabilities than any other public cloud
so the three use cases that I'll be
covering today are content storage and
delivery and so this this ranges from
everything from video and music
streaming website hosting multimedia
offerings mobile app development it's
it's any sort of use case where you have
content and you're bringing it out to a
to a large user base possibly within a
continent possibly globally compute
analytics and machine learning of course
are is a very important area that's
receiving a lot of attention these days
and here you see a lot of use in
manufacturing genomics ecommerce
Internet of Things all brings customers
to cloud storage and then finally I'll
cover the backup and archiving use case
which is a particular interest for our
near line and cold line products right
so long-term archives of content where
it's not being accessed frequently but
when you do need it you want it to be
there so some of the most important
features
it's a unified experience so I'll be
talking about different ways of storage
storing your data in cloud storage but
no matter how you store it it's the same
API regardless of storage class it's
always strongly consistent so when you
store data and then you do a bucket list
sting of that data a short time after
you're guaranteed to see the data that
you just wrote and that's not always the
case with cloud storage offerings and
that simplifies application development
we offer a wide array of geo redundancy
offerings so not only just picking you
can of course just pick one region and
we'll store your data in that one region
but if you want to actually have
automatic replication and have your data
served from multiple regions to isolate
you against the very rare possibility of
a region wide outage we offer a variety
of ways of making that happen and then
finally you saw the network that I just
showed you for Google well that allows
us along with the data centers that
we've put in place to have your your
data be scalable up to exabytes of
content so in our case petabytes of
content is not a scary number
hundreds of petabytes even or is
something that can be very easily
accomplished exabytes we may want to
plan a little bit for it but we have a
lot of a multi exabyte in data centers
and installations as well so what are
the key terms for object storage so
first of all what's an object that's the
most base piece that's actually you're
typically a file that you've written as
an object to a particular location and
this has an object name associated with
it where do you store objects inside
buckets so buckets are the container all
of the objects go inside you have a
bucket name where our buckets where do
buckets go
well that's locations so a location for
cloud storage is you either pick a
region or a multi region which
encompasses multiple regions I'll talk
about that in a sec and that's and that
location is where the bucket is
associated with and all of the contents
for that bucket all the objects end up
being stored within that location and
then finally we have the concept of a
storage class and a storage class is
nothing more nothing less than
determining the access frequencies that
you expect your objects to be to be
served at it's of the availability
levels and how important the
availability is and it also sets the the
pricing profile right so an object that
has to be served a lot and a more of a
hot tier of
is charged for at a higher level than
then archive data so there are two types
of locations for cloud storage one is
the multi regional offering and the
other is regional in nature and your
regional offering which is very similar
to what is available with with other
with competing cloud offerings you
basically you pick a region anywhere in
the world and your data is is stored
within that region multi-regional is is
interesting because we automatically
offer geo diversity as part of the
storage offering so we'll replicate data
across more than one region within that
multi region and a multi region is
usually a continent so we have a u.s.
multi region for example that that
constitutes all of the large data
centers that Google has within the
United States similarly we have one for
the European Union call it called U and
we have one for it for Asia as well so
that allows you to pick a continent
basically just create a bucket a bucket
in that continent and we will
automatically store the data in more
than one location within that continent
and so even if there's a hurricane or
some major event that takes down a
region as unlikely as that is your data
will still be immediately available from
the other locations and that replication
is done without having to set up a
replication service or or manage it in
any way it stays a single namespace so
I've talked about a little bit of this
already but one of the one of the key
distinctions between making that
decision between regional and
multi-regional comes down to trading off
performance predictability and high
throughput for co-locating your data so
if you are for example running analytics
workloads and it's very important that
your GCE installation is in the same
region as your data that's something
that you can accomplish very easily with
with regional storage with multi
regional as you'll see this while it
doesn't allow that tight colocation of
data and does result in a little bit
higher latency it's it's perfect for
content serving and other areas where
the goal is to is to host that data and
make it available across the Internet
so store I mentioned storage classes a
couple of slides ago and storage classes
basically determined how that how the
data is stored so part of it is is
whether it's multi regional regional
those are basically our our storage
classes for hot data so it has the
highest service level agreements
associated with them also of course the
higher pricing to reflect the the higher
SLA s and the higher performance and
then we also have near line and cold
line offerings that basically allow you
to tear your storage down to lower-cost
offerings where you don't expect to be
to be accessing your data frequently so
this this shows the data placement at a
very very high abstracted level so don't
be distracted by that some of them have
two boxes and others have one in all
cases the storage is there with very
high durability so we're talking about
11 9s worth of durability it's it's
what's shown here is actually the
availability model across regions right
so multi regional storage class means
that the data exists in more than one
region with regional and Nearline and
cold line classes they're stored within
one region but they're still stored
across availability zones allowing large
sections of the data center or within a
metro area to go offline with the data
still being accessible so no matter how
you store and no matter which storage
class it is the storage is highly
durable it's just a question of that
additional question of the the regional
isolation against potential regional
outages so that's the brief introduction
now I'm going to go ahead and start with
a content storage and delivery which is
the first major use case for cloud
storage so they're actually for common
setups that we see with content serving
and the simplest to understand is direct
serving basically you put your content
in the cloud and you serve it directly
from the cloud you pay egress rates
based on where the data is being read
and you take advantage automatically of
all of the edge caching and and points
of presence that Google has everywhere
however we also have a cloud CDN
offering and what this does is it allows
you to actually save on the cost
associated with egress if the data is
already cached it also allows you to to
take advantage of of some some
additional security offerings I'll get
into some more details there in a moment
there's also the ability to do custom
front ends if you want to have
additional intelligence and more dynamic
content and then finally you can also
use Google Cloud storage in conjunction
with independent CDNs so these are all
possibilities let me go into some more
details on the next couple of slides so
direct serving what would what would the
best practices be for direct serving so
one of them is to use the multi-regional
class this ensures that you have high
availability for all of your data and
with that with that geo redundancy and
you can also set cache control headers
to enable edge caching so let me let's
let's go ahead and take a look at a demo
to see how we you still get some
advantages from from our local caching
here we have a sample bucket I've
created it's called IO 107 - demo and
what I want to show you is that this
bucket was created in the Europe
location it's a multi regional bucket so
it's pretty far away from us okay and
I've created an object in here called
Google PNG and we can go ahead and open
that up and it's the Google logo so
nothing too special here so far I'm
gonna go ahead and open up the developer
tools here and this will give us a
little bit of timing information for
loading this this PNG and you can see
that when I reloaded it it took about
three hundred sixty-six milliseconds and
that makes sense because this this asset
is hosted all the way in Europe so first
of all what I wanted - one thing I want
to show is that even though this object
is in Europe it's actually using
Google's global network and it's
connecting right away and most of the
request is actually transited on
Google's network and one way we can we
can take a look at that is by running a
trace route
the domain here storage tocqueville
api's column so let me go ahead and do
that okay and so this is this is tracing
the path to the server and you can see
here at the very end one of the things
is the latency it's about five or six
milliseconds so this is clearly
somewhere closer than Europe and we can
actually take a little bit in a little
bit closer look to see where that is so
if you look at this server name it's
actually a little bit interesting it
says nu Q and then a few other things
it also says one of you one hundred net
so what does this all mean well first of
all one year one hundred Donette if you
search for the definition of Google
which is actually what our company you
should have been named but we misspelled
it it's a one each one hundred so this
is kind of a like a code name for a
device that we own okay and what about
nu Q and your Q ends up being Moffett
federal airfield which is an airfield
pretty close by here in San Jose the
devices aren't actually located in the
airfield but it gives you a hint that
we're ending up terminating the
connection somewhere in the Bay Area
right and once we terminate that
connection we then go ahead and and
translate the request across our own
network all the way to Europe
so okay so so most the request is mostly
transiting over our network but it is
taking a long time so in order to enable
edge caching it's just a simple matter
of changing the cache control headers so
here I want to change the cache control
headers from no cache to public and now
if I go ahead and reload a few times you
can see that it's gone down from about
300 400 milliseconds down to about 15
milliseconds and that's because this
this asset is now being served directly
from the adage cache here in the Bay
Area so okay thank you very good so and
now let's change back to the content
great so now we've seen the the edge
cash in action so I think that hopefully
gives you a little bit of a clue as to
why content delivery is such a good fit
for for cloud storage and so what what
about cloud CDN you ought to
automatically get some advantage from
that from that you just saw with a demo
but cloud CDN is an additional offering
that allows you to control the the
custom domains so if you want HTTPS if
you want to take advantage of some
differentiated pricing by not being
charged egress lower egress pricing if
when when you're correctly hitting the
edge caches and it also allows you to to
handle static and dynamic request
handling from the same domain so some
some some valuable additional features
you can also do custom front ends and
this can be done with or without cloud
CDN but basically this allows you to
also have a GCE instance doing some
custom dynamic transforms of data
authorizations that sort of thing
in the in the path and then the data is
served and again it can be cached so we
see a lot of either direct serving or
the use of cloud CDN and or custom front
ends it all depends on the the nature of
the of the content delivery requirements
so the final aspect here is is using
independent CDN so yes Google provides a
lot of offerings that allow you to do
all from from Google but they're
actually a lot of valid and very useful
reasons why you might want to consider
using an independent CDN as part of the
picture as well so we have partnerships
with Akamai CloudFlare fastly high winds
level 3 limelight Verizon and others and
all of them offer specific features
reach a redundancy for their particular
network they may be specialized for a
particular industry they may have
offerings and features that you want to
take advantage of that we don't have yet
and and really the the thing that you
need to consider when you're using an
independent CDN is is basically the the
concept of an origin shield and where
what where that's located geographically
so typically with an independent CDN
instead of using a a multi regional
class you should actually use a regional
storage class and the reason for that is
you can Co locate it close to where the
origin shield is for the independent CDN
that origin shield is basically the
block between ensuring that that not too
much egress happens from from Google
right so it helps control your costs and
and keep the the caching within the
within your independent CD n ok so with
that that's a that's a brief
introduction into the content delivery
direction with with cloud storage and
now I'd like to bring Michael back up
and he will talk a little bit about
compute analytics and machine learning
thank you Jeff
ok so I'm gonna cover essentially data
processing use cases and there's quite a
lot of variety here so I'll quite a lot
of variety quite a lot of specialized
tools and frameworks and services you
can use so we're not gonna have enough
time to go into those so we'll instead
cover a few generic best practices and
rules of thumbs that should apply to
most of them so let's first take a look
at how GCS or cloud storage is used
within these data processing pipelines
and the first case is source data right
this is the primary inputs into your
pipeline cloud storage is pretty popular
because there's a variety of different
data formats and object storage doesn't
really care what your format is for most
pipelines you end up reading the
majority of your data so you really care
about Adria throughput so the key thing
here is to use regional and to co-locate
your storage with your compute that's
going to give you the highest aggregate
throughput it's going to keep all of the
transfer within the in region network ok
the second type is intermediate data
this is data that's produced by one
stage your pipeline and then consumed by
another stage of your pipeline and
here's a little bit trickier if you care
about data persistence for example if
your pipeline is doing something
expensive and you want to be able to
resume the computation midway through if
something goes wrong then GCS makes
sense to use and in in that case the
recommendation is the same go ahead and
use regional and Co locate your storage
with your data however in some cases it
actually makes sense to not use GCS and
to use something a little bit more
transient where you don't care about
persisting this intermediate data and
you can get
the higher throughput so for example in
some Hadoop cases you can use HDFS and
run run HDFS on top of persistent disk
or local SSD and that'll enable you to
scale even higher we also have things
like cloud dataflow which authorized
offer more specialized services like a
shuffle service for specific operations
and so when you can use those those
sometimes makes sense rather than than
running your own and using GCS as
intermediate data third type is side
inputs and staging data so unlike
primary inputs primary inputs you
typically divide your inputs into shards
and you distribute them to various
compute nodes side inputs are inputs
that you distribute to all of your
compute nodes so this might be for
example some a mapping table which each
compute node can then transform your
primary inputs with similarly staging
data is any data that you would stage on
each of your compute nodes beforehand so
here you can go ahead and use GCS you
can use regional but it's actually okay
to use multi-regional as well if you
want higher availability and the reason
why is that because you're at doing
repeated reads Jesus will automatically
cache your data locally and so those
repeated fetches will come from within
the region and you're not going to be
constrained in terms of aggregate
throughput and then finally final
outputs this one's a little bit trickier
the storage class recommendation really
depends on what you're gonna do with
those outputs right so if you're going
to use these outputs to do content
serving you might use the
recommendations that Jeff just gave for
content serving if you're gonna use them
to feed into another pipeline then you
might use the recommendations we gave
earlier for source data so it really
depends on your use case to determine
what kind of storage class you want to
use okay so next one common question we
get is how large my objects be how if I
have a large object should I fetch that
in chunks if I want to upload an object
should I upload that in chunks and to
understand the recommendation here we
actually need to take a look at the
performance profile of cloud storage
these are very very rough rules of thumb
I've rounded them up to make them a
little bit easier to remember their
powers of two as well roughly and here
we see that we have about a 100
millisecond time to first byte on reads
we
about a 200 millisecond fix latency
costs for rights now as the object sizes
get larger you're able to achieve 800
megabits per second on read and foreign
and megabits per second on writes
so the key thing I want to call here is
that there's a relatively high fixed
latency cost per request and so that
means if you're going to be doing a lot
of small requests and you're doing them
serially you're paying that latency
every time and your aggregate throughput
it's not going to be great and that's
what this graph on the right hand side
is showing the smaller the request size
the lower the aggregate throughput
you're gonna get when you're issuing
these requests sequentially so the
general best practice is to favor larger
request sizes and object sizes whenever
you can we recommend typically 2
megabytes or larger if possible it's if
you do need to do a smaller request size
go ahead and paralyze a small requests
so for example one of the one of the
common things we see are people move an
existing pipeline over to the cloud and
they might have something like they
might list files and then perform some
operation on each file one by one if you
instead paralyze those you're going to
be able to get a lot better overall
throughput so next I want to talk a
little bit about auto scaling for a
storage and some of the best practices
there and to understand that we have to
look at how cloud storage ends up
sharding or splitting up your data so
cloud storage uses something called
range based sharding what that means is
it takes your data and it splits it into
lexicographical ranges and so in this
particular example we have three ranges
a through G G through s and s through
the end of the alphabet and any object
whose name falls within the range will
get assigned to that corresponding shard
so for example if I have an object that
starts with B it will fall into that
first shard a through G okay and the
reason why we do this type of sharding
strategy is to provide consistent
listing so imagine I want to list all
the objects that start with T this is
actually pretty easy to service it
simply needs to query a single shard and
that shard has all of the information
needed to respond to that query
so in contrast if you look at the hash
based charting approach this approach
you essentially for example you would
hash the name of the object you might
mod it by four and then assign objects
to shards based off of that mod and if
we were to if we were to service us
saving this objects request the problem
is we now no longer know which shards
contain objects that start with T so we
have to query every single shard right
and what happens if a shard is slow like
that yellow arrow or a shard returns an
error error like the red arrow in that
case we have a tough choice we can
either wait or ignore the error in which
case we're returning an inconsistent or
incomplete listing I'm sorry yeah we
could either ignore the error in which
case we would be returning a incomplete
listing or we could retry or serve the
error in which case we'd be providing a
higher error rate overall and you can
tell like as the number of shards
increases this becomes a bigger and
bigger problem so this is why we use
range based shorting okay so GCS like I
mentioned it automatically scales so it
will detect when a particular range is
getting hot in this case G through s and
we'll go ahead and split that into two
smaller ranges to try to split the load
evenly and so this happens automatically
and most of the time you don't have to
worry about it generally speaking you
can get about a thousand writes per
second in about five thousand reads per
second without having to worry about
anything at all beyond that it often
takes up to about 20 minutes for GCS to
figure out that a char needs to be split
and it will go ahead and split that so
for many use cases you really don't have
to worry about this however if you are
scaling up beyond some of these numbers
then one of the things one of the best
practices is really to make sure you're
distributing your load evenly this
really helps out our Auto splitting
algorithm to scale load evenly so I'm
going to talk about this in a little bit
more detail and one of the most common
ways that load is not distributed evenly
is sequential access so I'd like to I'm
going to go through a little bit of
detail to kind of give you a flavor for
why this is so challenging to deal with
so imagine we have sequential access
we're accessing objects g h i j k etc
all the way through q and imagine we had
split our shards like i showed in the
previous slide so we have a shard of G
through N and another shard and through
R okay the problem here is that when you
do sequential access the first set of
accesses all hit one shard the G through
n shard right and then once you get to
the second half of the accesses they all
hit the second chart the end through our
shard and so at any given point in time
you're still lasering or hot spotting a
single shard and splitting those shards
hasn't really distributed that load
across the two shards evenly so this is
this hasn't really helped us scale right
you might ask well how can we get around
this in one of the ways we need around
this is to further split into more
shards so here's an example we've split
it into very fine grade shards each
shard is only taking a single letter at
a time and so this definitely works in
terms of scaling load but the problem is
that there's fragmentation and
fragmentation again basically boils down
to how do you provide consistent listing
right so again when we only had two
shards issuing a listing request only
needed to talk to say one shard at a
time versus now with many many shards
the same listening request is going to
have to split up and talk to multiple
shards at the same time and we run into
the same problems where any one shard
can be slow or can return in air and
that will cause a listing problem so
this is this is essentially a
fundamental trade-off between strong
listening consistency and hot spotting
okay so here are a couple of ways you
can work around this if you're doing
bulk operations and they're doing them
sequentially you can try to do them in
parallel under different prefixes and
this will cause in this particular case
foo and bar are different prefixes GCS
will notice that there it is consistent
load to each of those prefixes it will
split and you'll be able to double your
total through player you can achieve
similarly if you don't care about
listing order you can hash the object
name and insert that hash somewhere into
the object name prefix and this will
cause your load to essentially randomly
hit essentially hit of what looks like
random object names which will provide a
nice distributed load and the nice even
load so again the drawback there though
is that your listing order is going to
be different okay next one talk about
timeouts and retries in its sounds try
but it's really important for data
processing workloads because you're
typically spiking up in your in your
traffic and you're more likely to hit
some temporary bottlenecks right and so
generally when people think timeouts and
retries use exponential back-off and
jitter and we're done right there's a
little bit more complicated than that
so aside from using back exponential
back-off and jitter the first
recommendation we have is to use idle
timeouts instead of absolute timeouts
and the reason why is imagine that
you're the system temporarily has
constrained bandwidth and you've set an
absolute timeout of two seconds but your
request needs I don't know let's say two
and a half seconds to complete what
you'll end up doing is you'll end up
waiting for two seconds canceling your
requests retrying it waiting two seconds
again cancelling your request and you
never end up making progress
right so if you instead we're tracking
when was the last time I made progress
and after two seconds of no progress
canceling your requests then you end up
handling this case much more gracefully
you'll go ahead and allow the entire
replies to take two and half seconds and
you're gonna be able to achieve positive
good play even though throughput or
sorry available bandwidth is decreasing
the second recommendation aside from
exponential back-off in jitter is to use
new connections for retries so the
reason you wanted to do this is that if
you get an error it's oftentimes because
you happen to hit one of the machines
that are in our large fleet and that
machine might be acting up we again we
have many many machines and so it's
possible that any given machine is
unhealthy for a period of time so by
establishing a new connection you're
you're increasing the likelihood that
you connect to a new front-end machine
and you're not reissuing the same
request to a unhealthy front-end machine
the third recommendation is make sure
you use item potent sequences so
whenever you are issuing retries if
there if it mutates state you're at risk
of having unintended consequences and
the common pattern we end up seeing here
is folks who issue a delete so imagine
you issue a delete request and that
request is taking a long time so you you
stop waiting you issue it again okay and
the second request succeeds quickly
because you've used the previous
recommendations it had hit a new machine
and now you've gone ahead and you to
leave your object now imagine you write
a new version of that object okay and
you so you've got a newly created
version and that succeeds as well and
finally what happens if that very first
request that was taking a long time
actually ends up succeeding well that
very first request is going to delete
the newly created object and all of a
sudden you have data loss so this is
pretty severe if you're not careful
about it right so when when you say use
item potent sequences there's a couple
of ways you can do this one way is to
simply make sure you only write and
never overwrite an object and that's
maybe pretty draconian in terms of what
you're able to do another approach is to
use something we call preconditions
which allows you to add a precondition
it allows you to add a condition to a
request that causes a request to abort
if that condition isn't met so in that
previous example I could have said
please delete object a only if its
generation number one and if I did that
then when I created the object a later
on it would have a different generation
generation number two and now that slow
delete request would no longer apply to
that generation and it would be harmless
right okay the fourth recommendation is
to limit retry volume and a rough rule
of thumb is to limit your retry so
perhaps 10% of your total traffic the
rationale here is that if the service is
truly unhealthy then additional retries
beyond this won't really help
and so retries are typically for the
transient sort of low error low heir
percentage case
this helps up the services clearly
because you're not slamming it but it
also helps out your client want to think
common things we see is clients will
retry indefinitely and they'll end up
building a queue within within
themselves and it causes the client to
fall over so this ends up helping if
with flow control a bit if you limit
your retries and finally the last
recommendation we have it's a little bit
of an advanced technique so you really
should only use this if you really need
to control your tail agency but it's to
go ahead and use a head request and a
head request is essentially a request
that you issue if your initial request
doesn't come back in time so for example
you might use your p95 latency I gave a
rough rule of thumb about 100
milliseconds for reads and you might
wait a hundred milliseconds for that
initial request to come back if it
doesn't you can issue a second request
and in most cases if you got unlucky and
that first request happened to hit just
one of the rare unhealthy machines the
second request is going to complete very
quickly typically under 100 milliseconds
right 95% of the time so this means your
99.7 5% latency will be under 200
milliseconds with this with this
technique in though in the rare case
where the system is overloaded the
initial request is still ongoing and so
you can go ahead and wait for that to
complete as well and so this doesn't
really have too many drawbacks as long
as you are limiting the total number of
retries that you are issuing so this is
again an advanced technique if you're
interested in there's a great paper
called The Tale of scale written by Jeff
Dean and you can look that up and it
goes into a little more detail on how to
do this okay finally I wanted to talk a
little bit about the Hadoop use case
because I know a lot of folks are have
Hadoop workloads on Prem and they're the
thing about how to move it to cloud and
I wanted to mention that we have a
service called data proc it's a managed
to dupe service it allows you to bring
up new clusters it implements a lot of
the best practices that we've talked
about in particular it configures HDFS
with local SSD by default so you can use
that for temporary data or intermediate
data
it also installs a Hadoop file system
connector for GCS by default as well so
what this allows you to do is allows
your Hadoop jobs to access source data
directly from GCS without first copying
it into your HDFS cluster a lot of the
best practices we've already talked
about using local SSD paralyzing small
operations the other thing I wanted to
mention the biggest difference I think
folks folks find when they move from
on-prem hadoop to the cloud is that
cloud storages is a object storage not a
filesystem so it doesn't have true
directory semantics for example it
doesn't support atomic directory rename
so this will oftentimes require you to
tweak your job a little bit for example
one common pattern we've seen is folks
will write files into a temporary
directory and then when that temporary
directory is complete they'll atomically
rename that directory into a final
location and that signal is a later part
of their pipeline to say hey all my data
is here so because cloud storage doesn't
support that atomic directory operation
an alternative method is to write your
objects into the final destination and
when all of your objects are complete
you can write a success file and the
presence of that success file says hey
the next stage of the pipeline is ready
to go so there are there are some tricks
with this that you might need to do to
update your pipeline to get to work to
work around the lack of directory
atomicity ok with that and when I hand
it back over to Jeff to talk about
backup in archive great so backup an
archive is the last area that we'll talk
about today and a little bit a little
bit shorter because this is a relatively
simple but important area and you know
here we have both do we have two
different cool storage classes so we
talked about the the different hotness
and coolness of data and the the main
multi-regional class and regional
classes those are those are hot tier but
if you want to to tear down to in
frequently accessed storage this is
where near line and cold line come into
play so the and here the difference
there
they're all of all of the storage
classes or instant access speeds so
you're never like waiting for data to
come off of tape it's it the latencies
are very similar across all of the
storage classes you're always using the
same api's so that's also consistent and
you always benefit from strong
consistency so they're actually there's
more commonality across the different
storage classes and there are
differences but those differences come
down to what is the ideal access
frequency and for Nearline you'll find
that of course you can access more
frequently than this but if you limit it
to no more than once per month then your
pricing will end up being really
advantageous to be in the Nearline
storage class and similarly if you
access if you expect to access less
often than one once per year for for
truly cold archive data then you'll
benefit strongly from from using a cold
line class so the way that this is
priced is basically the hot tears you
pay more per gigabyte month but on the
flats but on the flip side there's
actually no retrieval charge in the hot
classes for near line and cold line you
start to pay more for retrieval as your
storage class goes down and but your but
the performance behavior is very
consistent so the use case is for near
line and cold line because of that
frequency of access difference you tend
to see backups actually being more
associated with near line than cold line
anything around content serving where
it's a long tail archive that's just
it's infrequently accessed but it needs
to be available and and ready to share
that would be usually more of a near
line access pattern and then some some
adalah analytics workloads where the
data is very infrequently accessed
you're better off with near line cold
line is really much more about the long
term archives so tape replacement
disaster recovery implementations
multimedia source file storage where you
need to have it around but you're really
not accessing it very frequently those
are all those are all cases to use cold
line now these these storage classes
don't exist just on their own it's
really part of a larger
storage tiering capability that we offer
so you can use and you can set up an
automated lifecycle which will move data
automatically based on age of the
objects so this is just one particular
illustration here where you've chosen in
this in this example to say after 30
days move from the hot tears of either
multi regional or regional and move
those to Nearline and then after 90 days
of additional storage there move it to
cold line and then after a year delete
the data so maybe that's what your maybe
that's what your profile looks like if
it's not you could tweak this to however
you want it to be but that what's nice
is you can really set it up so that the
objects are migrated automatically down
to lower-cost storage as as the as the
age of the data increases so I mean
number one thing to say about backup is
just because it's cloud doesn't make it
automatic automatically protected
against every single possible incidence
and occurrence that might that might
occur just like in an on-prem there
they're either still backup
considerations that you need to take
into account for cloud so don't overlook
having a backup strategy number one we
provide a lot of features that the aid
you in in preventing accidental deletion
so a few of those that are the most
important include object versioning with
the lifecycle capabilities and be able
to lock down delete support for backups
so all of those help isolate you against
accidental deletion of data and
especially for for the backups of
on-prem data so cloud backup
capabilities the the general rules of
understanding what your backup windows
are and what your restore times look
like are equally applicable to cloud as
they are for on-prem backup um it's the
it's the latent cease and the the size
of the network pipes that are in place
between your your datacenter and in
clouds that count so understanding what
your throughput is how fast can you do
those backups how fast can you restore
that helps you as long as you can set
that up
to meet your business needs you'll be
set with with cloud backup and we do
sieve different deployment patterns for
backup we have the cloud backup we also
have cloud gateway Tights type setups
where there's a maybe a dedupe engine in
the middle there are a lot of different
ways to set this up I won't spend too
much time on this except to to to really
emphasize that one area that we've
really emphasized with the partner with
our partners is the native integrations
of cloud storage with our backup
partners so these are native
integrations taking advantage of all the
features of both our backup partners and
cloud storage and they include
partnerships with convolved Veritas
cohesive D actifi o rubric Dell EMC unit
wrens cloudberry labs others so this is
a very comprehensive portfolio of
partners and we encourage you to check
out those integrations for your backup
needs because it really simplifies
taking advantages of those best
practices and just making it happen
smoothly so with that I'd like to thank
you all for attending today so thank you
very much
you
[Music]